una de las principales diferencias entre
la vacuna de moderna y la de facer es
que la de moderna no necesita
temperaturas extremadamente frías para
su almacenamiento esto hace que los
estados que son los encargados de la
distribución local de la vacuna pues
puedan enviarlas a zonas menos habitadas
y también a hospitales rurales sin
embargo lo que las caracteriza de formas
y miles que las hace iguales es que
estas dos vacunas la de facebook y la de
moderna pues se aplican en dos dosis y
entre las dosis se deja cerca de un mes
de diferencia la próxima semana se
espera que de forma conjunta eeuu
distribuya 7,9 millones de dosis de
estas vacunas